i can't wait to hear what you have to
say about my squad i think they've had a
great year
i feel like a proud mama hen whose baby
chicks have learned to fly
interesting analogy surgeon chickens are
famously bad at flying
yo peralta has to be first which shows
how seriously he's begun taking his job
nope i just want to get this over with i
know these guys i know everything about
them well you're a poor police officer
if you don't think that people can
surprise you
not these people here watch this i know
what everyone's gonna do tonight it's
thursday
so gina's gonna leave early to rehearse
with her new dance group dancy reagan
they're the first ladies of movement
amy's gonna be going over her weekly
budget and charles will be attending a
pizza for one cooking class
tonight's menu pepper alone and if i run
and leap at terry he will most certainly
catch me in his arms coming in no
holding coffee
don't worry fire department is on the
job hear that jeffords we're gonna die
in here
we're marked for death okay calm down i
have an idea when my parents were
fighting my dad
got scary i would take my little brother
upstairs and to distract him
i'd teach him dance moves
or kind of dance moves mostly 80s
hip-hop he loves salt and pepper no
i won't be doing that
salt and pepper you say mozy forward
naming lights butt pop comb your hair
now typing motion pull it back jump
forward
pelvic pump you got it now all we need
to do is run it all together and do it
at full speed
i must say jeffords this dancing is
quite distracting i've completely
forgotten that we're trapped here in
this death box
inspected by bozo beverly between clown
shows you know what sir
i don't think you are thrusting your
butt enough
before the naming lights yes yes
i felt that god i love that note back to
the top
okay i'm saying five six seven eight
never let em play with the windows
that's parenting 101
and santiago i can't believe you didn't
stop it i'm sorry sir i knew it was
wrong and i did nothing which is
ultimately worse
cagney can't sleep without mumu and if
cagney doesn't sleep
lacey doesn't sleep and if cagney and
lacy don't sleep terry doesn't sleep
no jake doesn't live oh my god where did
you start letting them play with the
windows
uh on eighth it was close to the house
it better be the sitter leaves in 10
minutes and this is the last thing i
need
okay i'm so sorry about this sarge oh
and one more thing
i love you
i love you too jay hey sarge
why'd you want us to meet you out here
to thank you guys for the weekend
really it was a total disaster not a
total disaster none of us got sick from
that dog water
you drank that no look jake
you were right i have kind of forgotten
how to have fun
i'm gonna try to work on that so
oh the fireworks you made me surrender
when we re-entered new york
uh-huh fun terry's back
we're gonna set them off in a big pile
all at once by shooting our guns at them
what no no we're gonna set them off like
normal people oh
that's good too
here we go
[Applause]
see how fun this is original terry would
have been worried that we're standing
too close and need
safety goggles and he would have been
absolutely right we're way too close
friends
so are you bringing someone to the
wedding no i'm taking a break from
dating for a while
what i'm sick of asking people how many
siblings they have oh is it somewhere
between zero and two
how fascinating but you never know when
you're gonna find your dream person
anyone on the street could be that all
right it feels like you googled how to
talk to your bisexual friends
yeah the point is you can close yourself
off all you want the universe will find
a way that is the stupidest thing i've
ever heard
cars here hi i'm here to pick up rosa
are you the one i'm looking for
so i took care of sam uh oh that sounds
ominous
like you went oh miss miriam on her i'll
let him off with a warning
see the thing about miss miriam is she
made me a good dancer but she
ruined my childhood she was constantly
writing me about my posture and my
technique and my pink hair
drink her never speak of that copy she's
the reason i quit ballet
i sure as hell don't want sam to quit
the big brother program because of me
this is totally how i thought this miss
miriam thing was gonna go
another flawless terry plan also i've
loaded all of my favorite karaoke
backing tracks onto my phone
kevin and i will be duetting rolling in
the deep that's it
emergency squad meeting briefing room
two minutes
uh adult parties sergeant i believe
they're called
orgies no look five i met my wife at
norgie
well she was leaving in orgy and we
bumped into each other on the street
real meat cute thank you for exhibiting
exactly why this meeting is necessary
everyone here needs some instruction on
interacting with grown-ups
sergeant why am i here i'm always
incredibly appropriate
in high school i was voted most
appropriate ooh self-burn
those are rare i shouldn't be here
either i'm fine at parties
i just stand in the middle of room and
don't say anything here are the rules
no staring at your phones no rolling in
two hours late
no sweatpants no jeans and no shorts
what about dress-up shorts for instance
the kind jen aniston might wear
no those are still shorts no shorts and
everyone bring a bottle of wine
why are there so many rules i mean next
thing you're gonna say is we can't be
late
yeah that's like the first thing i said
ah
party huddle stop okay gang
we need a new strategy totally what is
going on out there
we can't tell cop stories kevin doesn't
find me charming and a native english
speaker referred to captain holt is
hilarious
i am flummoxed that's a word i learned
for this party and i am it
well i'm doing fine really raymond those
slacks are a knockout
do you think he heard that only because
you yelled it shut up
from now on we play to our strengths
charles you know everything about food
that's all you talk about
i mean i don't think anyone will ever
know everything about food it's an
evolving discipline
that's great stuff it's so boring don't
waste it amy
you studied art history that's
interesting scully
opera hitchcock nothing talk about
nothing
rosa stick with gina make sure she
doesn't say anything insane or steal
anything
too late don't worry it's just like hats
and scarves and stuff
she will put those back i will handle
the chit chat well that just leaves you
peralta what's your cultural specialty
easy kevin mentioned the new yorker and
i've totally read that
[Laughter]
keep a low profile chuckle anecdotes
try not to start any conversations got
it wait a minute
you're hitchcocking me well not
surprising we're practically twins
be appropriate on three quietly
one two three
now break it up we look weird
don't move as a group you're not
gazelles
wow we pulled it off nice eulogy
i thought it was dumb sergeant excuse me
you said there's nothing you can do to
bring him back but you're wrong
none of us are gonna stop fighting until
he comes home
thanks and if you ever need to talk or
get drunk or throw stuff off a roof i
mean i
i don't know your process am i hitting
on anything here the roof thing sounds
pretty good
very well let's throw something off the
roof and then we'll get back to work
high five i quite
like them now
you